we got a look today at the state of our
valley hospitals we're nearly a year
into the pandemic now and administrators
say
things have changed drastically since
the summer time
when they last met christian casar is
here now
live in studio to break it all down hey
there christian hey brian well we heard
from representatives from dignity health
sunrise
and henderson hospitals on what they're
seeing at the hospital campuses
we've been reporting that cases are
trending down across
our state and speakers on today's panel
said they've noticed that too they say
trends have changed have changed
so much since late december and early
january particularly following
the holidays where the hospital saw
record surges that's not necessarily the
case anymore across the state
or here locally even just over the last
couple of
weeks you know we've seen almost a 60
percent
reduction in the total number of phobic
cases you know
here in clark county and we're seeing
that same impact
on hospitalizations just in the last
couple of weeks
i think the hospital-like
hospitalization rate
i think across clark county has dropped
over 50 the panel said it hopes those
numbers will continue to drop
as people get vaccinated and remain
diligent about covet safety measures
the panel also mentioned at many
hospitals things are starting to return
to normal when it comes
to elective surgeries and of course
emergency room visits
christian casadas 8 news now